let's say that I have a huge maybe
frozen over Lake or maybe it's a big
pond so I have a huge surface of ice
over here my best attempt to draw a flat
surface of ice and I'm going to put two
blocks of ice here
so I'm going to put one block of ice
just like this one block of ice right
over here and then I'm going to put
another block of ice right over here and
then another block of ice right over
here and these blocks of ice are
identical they're both five kilograms
they are both five kilograms let me
write this down so they're both they are
both five kilograms or they're both of
their masses I should say are five
kilograms and the only difference
between the two is that relative to the
pond this one is stationary this one is
stationary and this one is moving with a
constant velocity constant velocity
constant velocity in this in the
rightwards direction and let's say that
it's constant velocity is at five meters
per second five meters per second and
the whole reason why I made blocks of
ice on top of ice is we're going to
assume at least for the sake of this
video that friction is negligible now
what does Newton's first law of motion
tell us about something that is either
not in motion or you could view this as
a constant velocity of zero or something
that has a constant velocity well
Newton's first law says well look
they're going to be at they're going to
they're going to keep their constant
velocity or stay stationary which is a
constant velocity of zero unless there
is some unbalance unless there is some
net force acting on an object so let's
just think about it here in either of
these situations there must not be any
unbalanced force acting on them or there
must not be any net force but if you
think about it if we're assuming that
these things are on earth there is a net
force acting on both of them both of
them are at the surface of the earth and
they both have mass so there will be the
force of gravity acting
downwards on both of them there's going
to be the the downward force of gravity
on both of these blocks of ice and that
downward force of gravity the force of
gravity is going to be equal to the
gravitational field of near the surface
of the earth times which is a vector
times the mass of the object so times
five kilograms five kilograms this right
over here is 9.8 9.8 meters per second
squared so you multiply that times 5 you
get 49 kilogram meter per second squared
which is the same thing as 49 Newtons so
this is a little bit of a conundrum here
Newton's Newton's first law says an
object at rest will stay at rest or an
object in motion will stay in motion
unless there are some unbalanced or
unless there's some net force but
basically what we've drawn right here it
looks like it looks like there's some
type of a net force it looks like I have
49 Newton's of force pulling this thing
downwards but you say no no no Sal it
you know obviously obviously this thing
won't start accelerating downwards
because there's ice here it's resting
its resting on a big on a big pool of
frozen water and so my answer to you is
well if that's your answer then what is
the what is the resulting force that
cancels out that cancels out with
gravity to keep these blocks of ice
either one of them from plummeting down
to the core of the earth from falling
from essentially get going into freefall
or accelerating towards the center of
the earth and you say well I guess if
these things are if if these things
would be falling if not for the ice the
ice must be providing the counteracting
force and you are absolutely correct
the ice is providing the counteracting
force in the opposite direction so the
exact magnitude of force and it is in
the opposite direction and so the if the
force of gravity on each of these blocks
of ice are 49 Newtons downward 49
Newtons downward is
completely netted off by the force of
the ice on the block upwards and that
will be a force of 49 Newton's upwards
in either case and now hopefully it
makes sense that Newton's first law
still holds
we have no net force on this in the
vertical direction actually no net force
on this in either direction that's why
they have a constant velocity this guy
has a zero velocity in the horizontal
direction this guy has a constant
velocity in the horizontal direction and
neither of them are accelerating in the
vertical direction because you have the
force of the ice on the block the ice
supporting the block that's completely
counteracting gravity and this force in
this example is called the normal force
this is the normal force it's 49
Newton's upwards this right here is the
normal force and we'll talk more about
the normal force in future videos the
normal force is the force when anything
is resting on any surface that's
perpendicular to that surface and it's
going to start to matter a lot when we
start thinking about friction and all
the rest so what we'll see in future
videos when you have something on an
incline and let's say I have a block on
an incline like this the normal force
from the I guess you could say this
wedge on the block is going to be
perpendicular is going to be
perpendicular to the surface and if you
really think about what's happening here
it's fundamentally an electromagnetic
force because if you really zoomed in on
the molecules of the ice if you really
zoomed in on the molecules of the ice
right over here even better the atoms of
the ice here and you really zoomed in on
the atoms or the molecules of the ice up
here what's keeping this this top block
of ice from falling down is that in
order for it to go through these the
it's it's molecules would have to kind
of compress against or I guess it would
have to get closer to the water
molecules or the individual atoms in
this ice down here and the atoms let me
draw it on an atomic level right over
here so maybe let me draw one of let me
draw one of this guys
let me draw one of this guy's molecules
so you have you have an oxygen with two
hydrogen's you have an oxygen with two
hydrogen's and it forms
big lattice structure and we can talk
about more of that in the chemistry in
the chemistry playlist and let's talk
about this ice is one of these molecules
so maybe it's maybe it's down maybe it
looks something like this and it has its
two hydrogen's and so what's keeping
these guys from getting compressed
what's keeping this this block of ice
from going down further is the repulsion
between the electrons in this molecule
and the electrons in that molecule so on
a macro level we view this as kind of a
contact force but on a microscopic level
on an atomic level it's really just
electromagnetic repulsion at work